one of my co-stars
um she had like a stalker she had
someone come to the show
oh really at the show and she she
got him out of the country like he
showed up and that was somebody was
sending these messages oh it's so creepy
and it's so creepy I know that you had
something like that and she was really I
was like what can I do I'll go handle it
I yeah you know I mean well and you
stopped going to cons because no no no
no I was afraid to go to them I was
stalked when I was teaching at
University of Pittsburgh
yep and it was terrifying it was before
the stalker
um law was even you know before Rebecca
Schaefer was murdered and uh it was
really really scary
um he almost I mean then when I got I
wanted to get out of there and there was
nothing I could do
um
it would just be everywhere he would
know where when my lights were off no
matter what he would I'd get uh I'd get
big missives that he would write and I'd
tear them up and then I'd just go a few
Paces away and then there'd be a new one
that would be in my purse I'd like how
has this happening it was like really
scary and he followed me when I changed
jobs and went to Brandeis and then he
had written all these open postcards I
didn't even know the people who had
hired me I'd met them once when I had
you know you you're sent and you're
supposed to be tested like do the
students like her you teach for a day
right you teach all the classes and then
they decide if they want to hire you and
I got this offer
as an assistant professor and um
I arrived there the first day in the
office and all the people in the office
are looking at each other like yes well
here here's some cards that have arrived
they're sort of personal and it was like
cards that he had written talking about
our relationship and all the and all of
which was fabricated and they just know
they're like they didn't know it was so
weird and then
that
winter like in December there was a huge
snowstorm and uh I mean nine feet of
snow had fallen and we were all trying
to dig our cars out so I was on this I
had gotten an apartment in Cambridge and
there were some people we were all on
the street trying to dig out the street
and there's a guy who we had seen each
other and he taught photography at RISD
Rhode Island School of Design and we we
were doing it for hours and he said hey
you want to come up for my place was
just to have a hot toddy or something
and I said sure I'd never met him that
was the first time I'd met him I go up
the guy's pairing a drink and there's a
knock on the door and open up and there
is my stalker and he grabs me by the
hair I mean it was like amazing and uh
what yeah I mean here he is in another
state on a snowy night and he was he
looked like Tony Perkins in Psycho it
was like scary
and this other guy had a fake gun and he
put the fake he went and got it and uh
and then we called the police and the
police said there's nothing we can do
until he hurts you and I said well he
grabbed me he assaulted me and that way
and they said no but we are there
bruises and I went well no because
yeah so I you know yeah I slept with a
butcher knife under my pillow for quite
a while how did it end it just sort of
trailed off he sent me Dead flowers I
just sort of trailed off he had flowers
and I never knew when I'd run into him
look the guy probably had mental illness
I don't you know I'm sure that he's
probably probably well I don't I don't
want to you know what if he was really
someone who just I don't know it was
really scary though and um that's why I
didn't want to go to cons because I
thought I'd see him because I was
inviting him inadvertently like look
I'll be out here I'll be right right so
I sort of was like always trying to not
do stuff like that